bonjour Catherine de roche merci
beaucoup de nous accompagner pendant
cette première demi-heure d'avoir
accepté notre invitation et ludmen et
loirement du groupe les républicains
vous présidez la commission des affaires
sociales et on va bien sûr longuement
parler de la réforme des retraites
puisque ça y est c'est à partir
d'aujourd'hui que le Sénat l'examine
vous l'examinez à partir de cet
après-midi en commission mais d'abord un
mot sur une autre actualité on a vu dans
le journal c'est la sécheresse hivernale
qui frappe le pays et qui inquiète
notamment les agriculteurs en plein
salon de l'agriculture Christophe Béchu
a réuni hier les préfets à qui il
demande de ne pas avoir la main qui
tremble pour prendre des mesures de
restriction d'eau dès maintenant il a
raison d'être ferme aussitôt je pense
que le problème de la sécheresse en
effet est là il faut prendre des mesures
ces mesures elles doivent néanmoins être
prises en concertation avec le monde
agricole le monde agricole et un monde
en souffrance on voit le dernier rapport
de notre collègue Laurent Duplomb sur la
ferme France a montré les difficultés
que rencontre notre agriculture qui a
été un des fleurons de la France qui est
aussi très présente dans Maine-et-Loire
et dans la région des Pays de la Loire
donc bien et à la fois les contraintes
que l'on fait aux agriculteurs mais ce
sont aussi des gens responsables qui
font beaucoup pour pour concilier
environnement et exercices de leur
profession et c'est des mesures doivent
être prises face à ces aléas climatiques
qui sont dramatiques pour les
agriculteurs ou les éleveurs se doit
être fait bien sûr mais en concertation
avec la profession agricole et l'un des
défis de l'agriculture c'est d'assurer
la souveraineté alimentaire du pays en
c'est l'un des thèmes d'ailleurs de ce
salon de l'agriculture alors Emmanuel
Macron Elisabeth borne ont tenté hier de
répondre aux agriculteurs il dit
répondent à ses besoins
de façon partielle et le rapport de
Laurent Duplomb et de ses collègues le
montraient bien il y a au fil du temps
une des difficultés qui se qui ont pesé
sur l'agriculture avec une perte de
compétitivité avec parfois des accords
de libre-échange qui pénalise fortement
notre agriculture et si on veut
maintenir cette souveraineté alimentaire
et notamment qu'il n'y ait pas un peu
des produits bas de qui arrive sur le
sur le territoire
et si on veut au contraire que ce soit
ouvert à tous les à tous les Français il
faut prendre des mesures peut-être un
peu plus fortes il faut pas entendre des
agriculteurs simplement au moment du
salon et les oublier entre deux salons
d'agriculture on va parler de la réforme
des retraites elle arrive au Sénat
aujourd'hui vous examinez le texte en
commission cet après-midi on fait le
point d'abord avec notre journaliste
parlementaire Audrey lui et
[Musique]
bonjour
et Audrey après des débats houleux elle
Assemblée nationale le projet de loi sur
la réforme des retraites quoi arrive
donc aujourd'hui au Sénat alors sur
quelle base quel texte a été transmis au
sénateur petit rappel d'effet d'abord
après 9 jours de débat compliqué c'est
un même féministe le projet de loi n'a
pas été voté par l'Assemblée il n'a même
pas été examiné dans son ensemble entre
les dizaines de milliers d'amendements
déposés plus le temps limité par la
constitution du fait de la forme du
texte les députés n'ont voté que deux
articles sur les vins que comportent le
projet de loi ils ont néanmoins eu le
temps de voter la suppression
progressive des régimes spéciaux c'était
l'article 1 et de supprimer l'index
senior c'était l'article 2 mais tout
change maintenant que le texte arrive au
Sénat comme il n'a pas été voté par
l'Assemblée on prend comme base le texte
du Gouvernement enrichit des éventuels
amendements votés qu'il voudrait
reprendre à son compte et vous le voyez
c'est le retour de l'index senior madame
de roche une question qu'est-ce que vous
avez prévu de faire avec cette index
senior qui a été rejeté par l'assemb il
avait été rejeté
nous discutons à nos collègues
centristes certains sont attachés à
l'index seniors qu'en fait un index
permettant d'avoir une vue sur les
entreprises de leur politique d'emploi
des seniors et de maintien dans l'emploi
des seniors moi je suis assez dubitatif
sur les faits néanmoins c'est un outil
de transparence qui peut être utile mais
nous souhaitons qu'il ne s'applique
qu'aux entreprises de plus de 300
salariés c'est une contrainte sinon pour
des petites entreprises et celle de plus
de 5 ans
si on le maintient on le maintiendra à
mon sens à 300 nous souhaitons le
compléter par une vraie politique du
maintien des seigneurs dans l'emploi et
c'est le projet de contrat de contrat
exactement qui consiste à ce que pour
des salariés de plus de 60 ans les
entreprises peuvent
contracter justement un dispositif de de
contrats de CDI de maintien dans
l'emploi des seniors jusqu'à ce qu'ils
puissent accéder à une retraite à l'âge
à l'âge défini après ce sera branche par
branche on pourra négocier les modalités
de ce contrat je pense qu'en effet la
Commission avait travaillé il y a
quelques années on n'est pas ça varie
moniquement sur la fin de carrière et si
on veut faire une réforme des retraites
telles qu'elle est appliquée nous
l'avions mis d'ailleurs dans nos items
du PLFSS
c'est bien de s'attacher aussi à
regarder comment on maintient en effet
l'emploi des seniors si on veut les
faire travailler plus longtemps il faut
leur donner les conditions pour qu'ils
puissent rester dans l'entreprise oui
parce qu'à partir entre 55 et 62 ans il
n'y a qu'un tiers des seniors qui sont
encore actifs ça c'est un chiffre un
vrai un vrai problème par rapport à
d'autres pays et alors ils sont ils ne
sont pas actifs alors où ils sont au
chômage ils sont
en maladie il faut pouvoir maintenir des
forces vives qui sont quand même celles
de personnes qui
souvent jusque 60 60 plus de 60 ans sont
en forme sont très actifs et apportent
beaucoup à l'entreprise faut travailler
aussi sur les questions des retraites
progressives oui oui
tout est décalé deux ans dans la réforme
ne souhaitons maintenir une retraite
progressive à 60 ans
pour l'instant elle s'applique au privé
nous verrons si on doit s'appliquer
aussi au public aux indépendants mais
avec dans cette période de 60 62 ans
peut-être quand même un maintien
d'employés d'emploi de 80% par exemple
et après pouvoir diminuer mais nous
souhaitons maintenir à 60 ans à la
retraite progressif on continue à parler
de ce texte en voudrait vous l'avez dit
les débats ont été quelques pulls à
l'Assemblée alors le gouvernement aucune
espoir concernant la tenue des débats au
Sénat oui il mise déjà sur le fait que
les débats seront plus calmes ça devrait
pas être trop difficile l'autre point
positif pour le gouvernement c'est que
la droite qui est majoritaire au Sénat
soutient le cœur de la réforme puisque
elle la vote chaque année dans un
amendement du budget de la Sécurité
sociale on va écouter Marc phéno le
ministre de l'Agriculture il était sur
votre plateau hier Oriane il s'est
exprimé à ce sujet
va remettre peut-être un peu d'ordre
dans les idées et un peu l'église au
milieu du village qui vous permettez
cette expression ça permettra d'aller au
fond des dossiers d'explorer le 1200
dans quel cadre il se met d'explorer les
dates butoirs les 43-44 le débat
infernal sur ce sujet là il faut qu'on
essaie d'expliciter de regarder sur les
carrières longues de regarder sur les
distorsions qui peuvent encore exister
pour les femmes donc j'espère bien que
ça permettra d'avancer sur des projets
d'avancer d'affiner le dispositif et de
d'éclairer nos concitoyens sur les
enjeux de cette réforme
l'exécutif a raison d'être confiant vous
allez soutenir le cœur de la réforme
nous nous allons soutenir une réforme
des retraites vous l'avez dit depuis
plusieurs années à chaque projet de loi
de financement de la sécurité sociale
nous votons un amendement à la branche
vieillesse pour pouvoir arriver à un
équilibre du régime on est dans un pays
qui a une dette colossale avec une
dépense publique de remboursement de la
dette ou des intérêts qui est une
dépense totalement
inutile alors que le besoin son
flagrants n'investissement ou de tas de
domaine qui partent à vos loups donc
nous souhaitons à équilibrer en effet ce
régime bon le gouvernement est gentil
des rencontres sur le Sénat nous ça fait
quatre ans qu'on le met à chaque fois on
se faisait
rotokisme n'était pas acceptée le
gouvernement d'Édouard Philippe nous
avons dû pendant deux ans une réforme
totalement inapplicable mais et
incompréhensible mais qui est quand même
arrivé au Sénat puisqu'elle avait été
votée en mars 2020 au 49-3 il n'a pas eu
l'idée de la reprendre donc ce qui
montre quand même la qualité de cette
réforme selon votre part sur la donc
elle était très compliquée et ce n'est
pas faute de l'avoir dit à Édouard
Philippe mais bon contact alors
maintenant le gouvernement se veut faire
une réforme en effet au bout de 6 ans de
6 ans de président Macron nous nous
allons faire un texte en effet qui
correspond
aux critères que nous avons toujours
défini et notamment lors du dernier
amendement au projet loi de financement
de la sécurité sociale sur les femmes
sur l'emploi des seniors sur les régimes
spéciaux sur la pénibilité sur la donc
nous allons mettre sur ces points parce
que
la réforme mais on va la modifier
on va voter un texte qui correspond à ce
que l'on définit chaque année en effet
on a on a parlé on vient de parler des
seniors il y a aussi sur les on veut
mettre l'accent aussi sur les maires de
famille
comment les maires de famille sont
pénalisés notamment dans le montant des
pensions il y a un peu la durée mais
surtout le montant des pensions donc
nous envisageons en sur côte pour les
femmes en prenant en compte les périodes
de maternité une surcotte de façon à ce
qu'elle puisse partir à la retraite avec
une retraite confortable ce qui n'est
pas le cas actuellement donc nous
souhaitons favoriser cette politique
familiale on a parlé de la retraite
progressive on veut aussi maintenir une
retraite à 60 ans pour incapacité
permanente parce que maintenir dans
l'emploi des personnes qui sont en
incapacité d'exercer le travail pour des
raisons physiques objectifs ça nous
semble aussi une question de justice
donc on va travailler un texte qui sera
le texte du Sénat et qui ne sera pas le
texte du Gouvernement même s'il y aura
des points des points communs bien
évidemment puisque le gouvernement est
venu sur à se rapprocher de ce qui était
notre position au Sénat mais il faut pas
inverser les rôles c'est le Sénat qui va
faire son travail et non pas le Sénat
qui va être à la boîte du gouvernement
pour pour faire un texte qu'il nous a
mis il y a quelques mois seulement sur
les femmes parce que c'est important
donc la position du Sénat c'est vous
l'avez rappelé de dire soit une surcote
soit un départ anticipé pour les femmes
qui ont trois enfants ou plus ça veut
dire que la sauvegarde du régime de
retraite elle passe aussi par une
politique familiale plus forte bien
évidemment le problème de la réforme des
retraites pourquoi en fait une réforme
des retraites pas pour pour pénaliser
les Françaises c'est pas pour le mais
c'est parce qu'il y a un vrai problème
démographique là où il y a quelques
années on avait quatre actifs pour un
retraité maintenant on va bientôt
arriver à un actif un peu plus d'un
actif pour un retraité il faut bien
financer si on veut garder un régime par
répartition et et ça finance en effet
par un encouragement de la politique
familiale et de la natalité qui au fil
du temps a quand même été dégradé depuis
quelques années par des politiques
familiales centrées exclusivement sur
les publics fragiles ce que je ne remets
pas en cause mais qui n'a pas encouragé
la natalité et de fait si on veut jouer
sur ce facteur démographique ça passe en
effet par une vraie politique familiale
c'est ce que nous allons faire dans ce
texte sur les 1200 euros Olivier du
socle a concédé ce sera 40 000 nouveaux
retraités chaque année qui pourront
bénéficier on sait que la droite est
attachée à la revalorisation des petites
pensions est-ce que vous allez faire des
amendements en sens peut-être pour
augmenter la part des personnes qui
pourront bénéficier pour l'instant ils
ne sont pas à l'ordre du jour de notre
commission on verra la commission cet
après-midi va s'attacher à à remettre
dans le texte
ce qu'on avait décidé en novembre au
projet loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale on a cette constance depuis
quatre ans on veut aussi l'avoir depuis
quelques mois donc nous allons plus nous
attacher par rapport aux items que l'on
avait déclinés à ce qui se traduisent
dans le texte et puis après on verra au
cours du débat d'autres mesures qui
pourront arriver telles que celles de
sur la fraude sur les pensions de
réversion pour les enfants
handicapés auxquels tient beaucoup le
président Retailleau et Philippe mouillé
au titre du groupe handicap il y aura
d'autres d'autres sujets qui vont venir
nous on va rester pour la vraiment
concentré sur ces items que nous on
avait décliné lors du sur les carrières
longues aussi puisque c'était c'est une
question est-ce que vous allez faire en
sorte vous allez demander que tous les
Français qui sont dans un dispositif
carrière longue ne cotise pas plus de 43
ans alors le problème de carrière longue
c'est que la première ministre a pris un
engagement de vent notre collègue
Véronique louvagi qui correspondait en
effet à la borne d'âge de 21 ans et puis
ensuite sont arrivés le vendredi des
amendements qui qui
complexifie le dispositif et qui surtout
dégrade beaucoup l'intérêt
financièrement le dispositif et nous si
nous voulons et d'horizon oui si nous
voulons vous allez pas les reprendre on
va voir ce que le gouvernement propose
parce que c'est le gouvernement qui va
nous proposer quelque chose sur les
engagements prêts à l'Assemblée
nationale nous nous souhaitons qu'en
effet peut-être un engagement soit pris
sur les bornes le reste relevant du
décret mais mais que ça ne dégrade pas
tout crawl et le dispositif parce que
sinon tendance à nous empêche totalement
de faire ce que l'on veut faire sur la
politique familiale sur l'emploi des
seniors sur les retraits progressifs ou
sur l'incapacité donc l'objectif c'est
c'est d'avoir aussi un équilibre du
régime parce que si c'est pour tout
lâcher et ne pas avoir d'équilibre aucun
Français qui travaille plus de 43 ans ça
dégrade trop le système pour vous ou
alors il faut trouver des compensations
il faut trouver ils mettent des critères
assez clairs parce que sinon ça dégrade
trop le système on va voir ce que le
gouvernement nous propose sur ce sujet
des carrières longues telles que tel que
ça avait été validé par rapport au
système actuel où il y a deux bornes
d'âge c'est très compliqué ces histoires
de bornes de carrière et autres le
régime des retraites est très compliqué
en fait lorsqu'on veut expliciter c'est
très complexe mais nous on souhaite en
effet voir ce que le gouvernement va
reprendre des engagements pris à
l'Assemblée nationale et là le
gouvernement s'éloigne trop de son
objectif initial qui est la sauvegarde
financière du régime pour vous il est
allé trop loin dans les concessions on
voit on voit au fil un effet des
concessions faites que qu'il y a en
effet il y avait au départ un chiffre et
puis on amène des déductions dessus en
sachant aussi que ce ne sont des
prévisions de chiffres dans un contexte
qui peut varier beaucoup avec des des
bases qui sont celles d'un chômage d'une
inflation de donc tout ça est très
aléatoire et puis il faut intégrer aussi
comment le fait de travailler plus
longtemps à porte des recettes donc ce
sont des chiffres un peu alors sans dire
à la louche parce que c'est peut-être un
peu fort mais ce sont quand même des
chiffres qui qui méritent une certaine
distance néanmoins on souhaite en effet
qu'on n'arrive pas à zéro du compte
parce que sinon pourquoi faire une
réforme qui mène les gens dans la rue si
c'est pour arriver à zéro et les
économies vous souhaitez notamment les
trouver sur la question des régimes
spéciaux vous souhaitez accélérer on
avait
mis au PLFSS convergence assez rapide
dès 2040 oui on va voir si on maintient
cette échéance très rapide ce qui est
clair c'est qu'il faut faire quelque
chose sur les régimes spéciaux mais ça
se discute parce que là l'amendement dit
dès 2040 c'est ça peut être en
discussion c'est pas une ligne rouge ça
peut être un discussion notamment avec
nos collègues nos collèguescentrices
ce qui est clair c'est qu'il faut quand
même avoir quelque chose sur les régimes
spéciaux parce que on l'entend les gens
disent vous touchez aux salariés mais là
j'ai une spéciaux vous ne touchez pas et
il y a quand même au fil du temps une
inégalité au sein de l'entreprise avec
les nouveaux entrants et ceux qui sont
rentrés juste avant la réforme et qui
eux pendant des dizaines d'années vont
bénéficier d'un régime différent c'est
assez compliqué en termes de gestion des
ressources humaines
peut-être oui sur les lignes rouges on
en a parlé à ce qu'il y a des choses que
vous voulez absolument pas voir dans
dans cette réforme de texte
l'une rouge pour l'instant on va être
sur un débat assez binaire nous nous
allons faire nos propositions on essaie
en effet on a essayé de s'accorder au
salam majorité au sénatoriale pour avoir
un
des amendements communs qui conviennent
à haut de groupe ça a été relativement
facile puisque ça m'était voté il y a
quelques il y a quelques mois après en
face on va être en effet sur une
position plus frontale donc s'il y aura
des lignes rouges les lignes rouges ça
va être en effet la suppression la
suppression de la réforme nous ne sommes
pas favorables donc à partir de là c'est
la seule ligne rouge que je vois pour
l'instant c'est un sondage au doxa qui
est publié ce matin pour Public Sénat et
la presse régionale qui dit que 87% des
Français veulent des débats dignes et
apaisés au Sénat est-ce que
vous créez une forme d'obstruction de la
gauche sénatoriale les débats seront
dignes apaisés la règle au Sénat on a
souvent des oppositions sur des textes
mais je vois au sein de la commission
des affaires sociales il y a une
ambiance tout à fait correcte qui se
passe bien mais avec les collègues des
autres groupes et on le voit dans tous
les débats en effet ce sera digne ce
sera pesé ce sera pas le grand guignol
comme ça peut être à l'Assemblée
nationale que ce joueur aucun sénateur
qui correspond à ce profil là mais
néanmoins ce sera ce sera ce sera ferme
il y aura des discussions après c'est en
effet combien de temps dure le départ on
a une
date limite que celle du dimanche 12
mars nous nous souhaitons aller au bout
du texte de tous les articles pour
pouvoir voter ce texte après comme on
n'est pas le cas de la gauche ce qui
n'est peut-être pas le cas de la gauche
on verra comment ça se passe et après on
va voir en effet comment nous avons
ouvert largement les séances pour
pouvoir avoir arriver au terme du débat
je trouverai très dommage que le texte
sorte sans vote au Sénat et qu'après
tout soit remis remis à la CMP je pense
que ce dire le président de la
République dont je ne suis pas un grand
soutien ce n'est pas quand même l'avait
mis dans son programme présidentiel on
ne peut pas dire que c'est il est
illégitime de le proposer de sa part ça
c'est malhonnête à tactilement merci
Audrey merci à tout à l'heure oui on va
parler calendrier justement de
l'ouverture des séances le week-end au
Sénat c'est la différence par rapport à
l'assemblée exactement on parle de tout
ça tout à l'heure on va aller voir
l'actualité dans votre département avec
nos partenaires de la presse régionale
on va à Angers on retrouve une très
cadurant bonjour Yves merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous reporters politiques au
Courrier de l'Ouest et vous allez nous
parler d'une autre actualité c'est la
colère des médecins
et oui parce que hier dans les rues
d'Angers ça manifestait mais ça
mobilisait quand même nettement moins
que que la réforme des retraites vous
êtes médecin de formation madame de
roche qu'est-ce que ça vous inspire ce
mouvement que pensez-vous aussi des
propositions du gouvernement notamment
celles qui vise à valoriser
le tarif des consultations pour ceux qui
accepteront d'aller s'installer dans des
zones moins dotées en médecins moi j'ai
oui prévu l'article du corps et de
l'Ouest ce matin
je me réveille je regarde le Courrier de
l'Ouest donc
j'ai vu l'article moi j'ai rencontré il
y a quelques à juste avant la
proposition de loi de Stéphanie j'ai
rencontré le Conseil de l'Ordre du
département j'avais appelé le président
et je lui ai proposé de rencontrer avec
des médecins du département j'ai été
très surprise d'abord du nombre de
médecins qui sont venus à cette réunion
qui était un peu confidentielle si je
puis dire mais aussi de leur de leur
désespoir et je pense que le
gouvernement ne prend pas la mesure du
du désespoir des médecins généralistes
il ne prend pas et il a en plus agité
des chiffons rouges qui sont qui étaient
inutiles nous nous avions demandé le
report de la loi risque qui qui était
sur un partage de tâches que l'on peut
entendre mais qui en même temps mettait
des des engagements territoriaux alors
qu'on est en pleine négociation
conventionnelle
loi de finances de la sécurité sociale
on nous a fait voter un article que l'on
a voté au Sénat disant une négociation
conventionnelle s'ouvre et dans cette
négociation des discussions auront lieu
avec les syndicats médicaux sur
l'organisation des soins en effet sur la
permanence sur la prise en charge des
patients et en même temps le
gouvernement sort un texte alors c'est
pas le gouvernement c'est une police sur
loi mais soutenu par le gouvernement
sort un texte qui a mis le feu aux
poudres nous nous avions demandé le
report le gouvernement n'a pas accepté
et je pense que le gouvernement ne prend
pas la mesure à l'impression je crois
que c'est un peu une forme de pression
pour la négociation non moi j'ai senti
un vrai désespoir des médecins
généralistes qui veulent déplacer et pas
que ceux qui partent en retraite qui
sont près de la raid leur activité qui
veulent partir plus tôt mais une vraie
désespérance en disant mais
quel avenir on nous propose et pourquoi
on est un peu les boucs émissaires d'une
situation qui n'ont pas provoqué
correspond tape sur ceux qui sont là on
tape sur ceux qui sont là qui
travaillent beaucoup qui moi tout ce que
j'ai vu travailler beaucoup est un
exercice coordonné
était participé à la permanence des
soins dans le département et on dit on
nous prend comme les boucs émissaires en
disant mais vous allez en voir plus on
veut bien vous augmenter mais
inconditions que il y a eu les annonces
du président Macron et ils ont
l'impression d'une forme de pression et
ils ont des craintes très fortes sur ce
que l'avenir du médecin généraliste et
la place du médecin autour du patient et
ça je pense que le gouvernement doit
l'installation en zone rurale qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez vous le
Maine-et-Loire est quand même un
département en majoritairement rural
avec quelques déserts médicaux est-ce
que l'incitation financière pour aller
s'installer dans ces déserts médicaux et
pertinentes est-ce qu'elle est
suffisante et par ailleurs est-ce que il
faut éventuellement contraindre les
étudiants en médecine aller s'installer
dans ces zones en début de carrière moi
j'ai toujours été aussi la coercition
par rapport
au médecin beaucoup de mes collègues ils
sont favorables tous les rapports et les
rapports de pays d'autres pays montrent
que ça ne marche pas on ne gère pas la
pénurie par la coercition en revanche
moi j'ai été favorable à ce que le
désinternes fasse une quatrième année en
médecine générale pour aller non pas
combler les trous des airs médicaux de
toute façon il y a pas de zone sur deux
t elles sont exceptionnelles les zones
surdité donc c'est plutôt d'amener en
effet des étudiants à aller exercer et
tous les ans en amenés un potentiel de
nombre d'étudiants en médecine qui font
aller travailler avec des avec des comme
docteur
junior avec des médecins des médecins et
qui vont découvrir ce que la médecine
générale qui vont découvrir le
territoire et qui finiront par s'y
installer donc moi je crois plus à cela
et je pense que c'est une mesure qui est
importante et puis pour le reste
on le problème c'est que là où on avait
un médecin maintenant il en faut
quasiment deux
l'exercice n'est pas le même c'est un
fait de société et c'est dans toutes les
professions il semble qu'il y aura pas
d’accord entre les médecins je trouve
demain d'accord et je pense que la
situation s'est tendue avec la
proposition de Loiry c'était et l'idée
de dire on vous donne quelque chose une
revalorisation tarifaire avec un tarif
quand même la consultation même si ce
n'est pas l'essentiel des rémunérations
total parce que c'est aussi des
rémunérations sous une autre forme
passer de 25 à 26,50 € les médecins ont
pris ça comme un peu une provocation sur
une revalorisation d'acte qui n'a pas
été fait depuis plusieurs années mais
vous comprenez vous qui refuse parce que
François Brune le ministre de la Santé
dit c'est pas responsable oui moi je
ne dirais jamais que le médecin ne sont
pas responsables comme je ne dirais
jamais que les infirmières ne sont pas
responsables je pense que les
professionnels de santé sont déjà
respons déjà responsables et moi j'en
vois beaucoup qui souffrent de ne pas
pouvoir voir de plus de patients mais il
faut les soulager tâches administratives
par les assistants médicaux il faut un
effet qui est un exercice coordonné
avec les infirmiers avec les autres
professionnels de santé mais que le
médecin quoi qu'on en dise et quand même
celui qui pose le diagnostic qui décide
du traitement et que ce soit lui qui
soit au cœur du dispositif avec les
autres et non pas qu'on le marginalise
et c'est cette crainte qu'on les
médecins que le gouvernement à mon sens
même si j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
François Brune donc le gouvernement ne
prend pas la mesure merci et je serai
qu'à durant la une du Courrier de
l'Ouest mobilisée pour sauver le médecin
de famille c'est à la Une de votre
journal un dernier mot Catherine de
roche parce qu'il nous reste une minute
mais sur la fin de vie vous travaillez
sur ce sujet au Sénat on attend les
conclusions de la convention citoyenne
ce sera le 19 mars mais il y a déjà eu
un premier vote 84 % sont favorables à
ce que la loi change 75% sont favorables
à une aide active à mourir faut modifier
la loi je pense que le vrai sujet il est
sur l'absence de soins palliatif sur
certains territoires
département je pense que la loi classe
Leonetti répond à une majeure partie des
des cas lorsqu'elle est appliquée
lorsqu'elle est si elle est bien connue
bien appliquée mais surtout on a ce
déficit en soins palliatif parce que
même sur des pathologies comme la
maladie de Charcot on disait peut-être
que c'est un peu une faille dans le
système moi j'ai vu des
maladies de Sharko qui accueillaient en
soins palliatifs avaient changé leur
vision nous allons faire un déplacement
en Belgique nous allons faire un
déplacement en Suisse
on veut aller voir un peu comment ça se
passe dans ces pays parce que il faut
faire très attention aux dérives et
qu'est-ce qu'une personne digne ou une
personne pas digne à quel moment juste
qu'une personne est digne de vivre le
padding la dignité aller jusqu'au
dernier souffle et on peut avoir des
dérives considérables
[Musique]
que vous ex aminez donc la réforme des
retraites à partir de cet après-midi en
commission et on va évidemment en parler
dans le club dans 20 minutes de cette
réforme des retraites et de cet examen
au Sénat et on en parle tout de suite
avec notre prochaine invité c'est
Michael Delafosse qui nous rejoint